so knowing that I would be the caboose
on this long train of speakers even list
today I'm sparing you powerpoints
pleasure to be would be with you today
to offer an investor perspective on
managing the risks from from shale
energy operations and I deliberately
refer to shale energy operations because
I want to be clear from the outset that
i am not talking about hydraulic
fracturing as technically defined we're
talking about the life cycle of shale
energy operations you probably don't
hear very much about about the investor
voice my organization the investor
environmental health network is a
collaboration of investment managers you
manage about 35 billion dollars in
assets those assets are in a variety of
sectors including the energy sector I
even though I'm not an engineer on a
political scientist I I follow the
engineering principle the KISS principle
I'm going to to keep things simple for
you some of what I'm about to say to you
as an introduction is going to strike
you as fairly elementary but I think
it's important to sort of lay the
groundwork for what follows so the
starting point for my presentations that
investors balance risks and rewards we
don't like uncertainty we don't like
nasty surprises in our investment
portfolios we are data hungry there is a
traditional there are the traditional
financial data dollars and cents
information about companies but there's
also information about the quality of
corporate management how how well
companies set up to establish policies
practices systems both to reduce risks
and not only just reduce environmental
risks but a lot of cases where reducing
environmental risks produce a bit bottom
line benefits for the for the business
how well set up are they to to pursue
those benefit those company benefits
from sound management practices the
investors I work with have traditionally
favored natural gas over coal and
nuclear energy but their confidence in
the last few years has been shaken by a
variety of incidents that have been
described to you earlier in the day
these incidents have led to bands in
moratoria as have already been described
to you beyond New York there is a
province of quebec canada this france
there's bulgaria it's a phenomenon that
that's occurring around the world either
bands or moratoria in the parlance of
investors we talk about the loss of the
social licence to operate which gets
back to the the introductory comments of
our moderator so investors began to ask
questions of companies no we know we
know that we know that the the industry
is very dynamic there's just a huge
amount of technological development a
huge amount of innovation goes on the
question is to what extent the corporate
management management's investing in
innovation to what extent are they
mobilizing technologies to reduce
environmental risks and to realize both
the environmental benefits and the
business benefits from innovative
technologies over the last almost four
years we've talked about 30 different
companies essentially what we say is we
ask questions well what are you doing
about air emissions what are you doing
about water emissions what are you doing
about about wastewater management what
are you doing about some of the
community impacts that that were alluded
to a few moments ago and then basically
what we do we say to the company's
listen it's all well and good that
you're telling us on the phone or in a
letter about what you're doing what you
really need to do is put the information
out there because of indeed your social
licence to operate is being challenged
then the general public aside from us
investors really ought to know what
exactly you're doing to address the
concerns that are in the headlines
almost every day or so it seems past a
certain point the company said to us
well look you know what exactly do you
want us to say and we found in a lot of
the conversations you'd say well look
water management well look at what a og
has written a chemical toxicity
reduction will go to in Cana air
emissions go to southwestern energy past
a certain point what we realized is we
needed to get beyond the anecdotal and
have a systematic way of saying to
companies look this these are the risks
that are our concerns to investors to
the larger polity and these are the ways
you ought to address them hence this is
the alternative to powerpoint old
hardcopy extra
acting extracting the facts and invest
your guide to disclosing risk from
hydraulic fracturing operations
hydraulic forgive me hydraulic
fracturing is in the title that's
because a communications person said to
me literally if you say shale gas
operations it won't show up anywhere in
the Google searches therefore even
though you're talking about something
more than hydraulic fracturing you got
to put hydraulic fracturing in the title
so that's what we did so that's December
2011 essentially we lay out 12 core
management goals we talk about Board of
Directors oversight of risks we talked
about contractor management as you all
know most of the employees out there on
the pads or contractors or not that
they're not the operator staffs we talk
about chemical toxicity reduction
fracfocus provides disclosure of
chemicals but doesn't provide any
information whatsoever about systemic
reduction of chemical risk on a company
by company basis which companies are
systematically working on on green and
chemicals reducing the chemicals they're
using that kind of thing we talk about
water sourcing we talk about wastewater
management we talk about community
impacts the principal now occasionally
there's been referenced today to best
management practices well I found in my
experience that the first thing that
happens when you talk about best
management practices is some technical
person in the audience will say but wait
a second here's an exception to the best
management practice you know for for
geological reasons for whatever reasons
this practice just doesn't apply so the
concept underlying extracting the facts
is comply or explain in other words it's
a bias is it default if you will towards
something like a green completion
there's there's a default towards
recycling waste water but if you're in a
circumstance where you can't do a green
completion where you can't recycle your
water or at least explain why you're
doing it so people understand that this
sound technological judgment that's not
merely a matter of oversight or lethargy
and that you're not doing these things
particularly in the case of air emission
control is like globally no bleed
pneumatic controllers green completions
the return on investment can be fairly
quickly and makes sense not only for the
84 for for the atmosphere but it also
makes sense for the business so we have
this core management goals we got the
best management practices and most
importantly have key performance
indicators both qualitative and
quantitative
if it's all well and good to say well we
you know we do these things what we want
to know is that you're doing a green
completion in one location or you're
doing them in fifty percent of your
locations if you're in Colorado if
you're in Wyoming and that's where most
of your operations are you're going to
be doing a lot of green completions
because those states require them if
you're in the Marcellus Shale of
Pennsylvania you are going to be doing a
lot of recycling because you don't have
deep well injection there unless you go
over the boundary to Ohio West Virginia
as was alluded to by Professor Wiseman
if you're in Pennsylvania you are going
to do your baseline monitoring because
if somebody goes after you you've got a
pretty heavy legal burden to to overcome
if there's a problem and it's not only
Pennsylvania West Virginia but it's also
now in North Carolina law and it's 5,000
feet around around the well for North
Carolina law so we drew on experiences
from 7 17 different different companies
that we've been dealing with I mean so
it's a short document it's deliberately
written for senior management of
companies you know we couldn't give them
a Bible of best management practices
guidelines that kind of thing is 35 page
document about a third of it at least is
footnotes with lots of detailed examples
from lots of companies around the
industry showing how they are already
implementing best management practices
essentially what we're trying to do is
drive a race to the top in terms of
adoption of best management practices
and we're also trying to strengthen the
voices of the progressive companies
within the industry the industry is
characterized by leader companies by
laggard companies as a certain
resistance to regulation as a certain
resistance to change despite all the
innovation but there are lots of folks
who understand hey listen we really you
have to communicate better about this
stuff there are legitimate concerns we
simply can't blow them off simply
because their errors in gas land or
whatever these are real concerns people
have them we really need to acknowledge
them speak to them and tell people
here's what we're concretely doing about
them we've gotten good support for the
guidelines of you know our organization
is 35 billion in assets under management
we have expressed support for the
guidelines from investors in Australia
all the major public pension funds
largest public pension fund in Europe
and investors in North America totalling
1.3 trillion
in dollars in assets under management
some progressive voices when the within
the industry have spoken up in support
of our guidelines that's Apache energy
talisman energy from Canada BG Group
from the UK and southwestern energy we
also have NGOs who have said kind things
about US Environmental Defense Fund
which is here Natural Resources Defense
Council EDF and RDC of course say we
need regulations that guidelines are
just voluntary but nevertheless where
you have an even regulatory situation
such as what's described is that my 10
minutes done well you have an uneven
regulatory situation the this investor
voice is an important voice for for
advocating enhanced practices in the
sense we are trying to fill a regulatory
void and and it goes beyond more than
simply unevenness and state regulations
even I mean what we're seeing is
tightening regulations overtime Ohio now
is pretty strong regulations North
Carolina intends to to regulate fairly
strongly at least so it seems Colorado
has tightened up regulation so there's a
trend here but but having laws on the
books is only one part of it do you have
the budget are you able to get skilled
personnel especially when you're
competing for skilled professionals who
can get paid three times as much if they
go into the oil and gas industry it's a
problem do you have the will to enforce
reference was made to act 13 which
basically preempted all the local
governments in Pennsylvania that was a
function of a change in the governorship
and and the new governor is is nowhere
near where the old governor was in terms
of being serious about enforcing
Pennsylvania's environmental laws I want
I want to stop here but and end on a
note of tribute to our moderator because
he chaired this advisory panel to the
Department of Energy Secretary they
reported shortly before we published
extracting the facts and here's what the
his committee had to say the
subcommittee urges leading companies to
adopt a more visible commitment to using
quantitative measures
as a means of achieving best practice
and demonstrating to the public that
there is continuous improvement in
reducing the environmental impact of
shale gas production this is what
investors are saying to to the companies
in which we own stock and this is what
implementation of extracting the facts
is all about thank you very much for
your time